so we're going to we are going to start
in one minute
you
welcome everybody sorry about the
weather anyway it's it's a sort of super
interesting moment of course it's a sort
of a threshold the actix have been with
us for three years and the planners for
two years and the historic preservation
students for two years and the PhD
students for two hundred and sixty-two
years and it's very weird that you're
going to leave it's kind of sad don't
know where you're going to go don't know
what you're going to do you came to us
from 50 different countries there are
alumni living alumni in 85 different
countries so somewhere out there you're
going to change the landscape I think
what's interesting is that is is the
school is very different from when you
started even those of you who started
just a couple of years ago it really
changes a lot from Yeti oh we're very
affected by by you which means that it's
quite possible that you leave the school
and you end up moving less than we do
because if you come back here the place
will have changed and this was always
the principal and maybe that's the
reason you came to us in the first place
that this is a school that travels not
just you go on York any trips and so on
but the school itself is on the move
it's very very exciting for those of us
who teach here because we really don't
know where the school is going nobody's
in charge or to say it another way
around there's a kind of ecology of
thinking which is pulling the school
endlessly in different directions and
the school goes where the best ideas
take us and the best ideas are exactly
that it's something that takes you
somewhere it pulls you somewhere you can
never be sure what a good idea is doing
to you it's actually only later that you
call it a good idea at the beginning
it's not even an idea it's a pool you
are find yourself moving in the
direction you're moving because your
friends are talking about something your
teachers talking about something the
world is talking about something because
somebody invented something that
something happens and you start
moving so the way I think of this is not
that you came to the school you sort of
SAT here in this very intense nuclear
reactor for your two years or your three
years or your four thousand years it's
the school itself was moving while you
were in here like one of those weird
insects 750 students with little legs
making that building of 19 and 11 Wanda
it's very very clear that when you came
to the school you knew that we didn't
know what we were doing right which is
to say it's the one school in the world
that says we don't know what
architecture is we've accumulated more
ideas about what it is than anywhere
else we have the reference library of
the field in theory we have more
scholars per square meter than any
school in the world in theory we have
all the answers but in reality we just
know what we don't know and we invite
you to join us to keep thinking about it
this is a school that actually thinks
that that's what architecture is that it
is the asking of questions not the
delivering of answers we don't see
architecture and planning and
preservation as sort of service
disciplines that simply fill a precise
need we see the architects the planners
and the preservationist and the scholars
as yes are dealing with the very real
questions and the very real practical
problems that you've been given but much
more than that making kind of
philosophical reflection upon possible
directions indeed suggesting to people
that they might be asking you for
something different and in truth the
only reason that somebody ever asks an
architect to do something is that the
architect will almost have almost always
have a way of doing that thing that
changes the question changes what it is
that you've been asked to do that's
exactly what an architect and planner
and urban designer and preservationist
is it somebody who thinks differently
and encourages other people to think
differently you have very weird people
there's no question your parents have
always known that when you said to them
that you're going to go to an
architecture school there was the sort
of sigh
okay what can I do you think that
buildings are talking to you human
beings do not think so human beings used
buildings the enjoy buildings they also
leave them behind they don't always
think about them for you the city is
alive it's constantly talking to you
about the past the prison and the and
the future and you're speaking to your
society pleading with them to see the
world the way you do and to think that
the built environment could capture the
highest ambitions for your society and
that's ultimately what what unites you
is that this thought that the highest
aspirations of society would be held in
the built environment which means that
when the world is in the worst possible
shape architecture has to be in the best
possible shape and this is this moment
surely it's in this moment that we need
our buildings to speak to us with the
greatest degree of eloquence we we super
deeply believe in the fact that you will
find ways of rethinking the built
environment practically philosophically
technically and so on the core
philosophy of the school is to believe
that you are better than we are that you
are facing questions in a different way
that we actually don't even know what it
is the question that you will have to
deal with the whole school is organized
around a kind of a trust we think the
future will be okay if we were to trust
you and therefore our role is to somehow
help you to be stronger or softer or
more sophisticated or more complicated
or more direct or more whatever that
will allow you in the future to be the
leaders that you should be in other
words the main purpose of the school is
to support something that didn't happen
yet to support the possibility of
something emerging in the future to
catch even the smallest trace of a new
philosophy a new technology a new way of
thinking a new sense of responsibility a
new combination of disciplines a new
discipline to catch that before it could
be
edge before it could be an academic
program before it could be a formula and
to allow it to to to grow to incubate
some new potential so essentially this
is a school in which probably there are
more intelligent people and more
intelligent people about architecture
than you will find anywhere else there
are people that could give you the
answers to more questions than anywhere
else in the world but in fact the whole
purpose of knowing everything that can
be known is so that we could together
jump let's say towards the unknown which
is just to say that education like
architecture is a form of optimism we
think we can help the future by trusting
you to do things that we we cannot do
which means as you know I believe deeply
in the thought that the only thing we
really have to take care of our ideas
you didn't have yet so the question is
how do you how do you nurture the
ability for somebody to be strong in the
future and this requires a kind of a
miracle teachers have to be super good
to survive you and in being super good
they develop it's a kind of a chicken
and egg situation where you provoke the
teacher to provoke you to protect the
end because like there's been Bing Bing
Bing Bing Bing you win you always win we
lose after all think about it what does
it mean to spend your entire life and
university who's the winner here who's
moving on to have a life not the
teachers right so you're the winners but
remember that this this is a long
conversation it's going to be a very
very long conversation the school is
famous of course it's famous for
changing the discipline it's the main
mission of the school to redefine
disciplinary capacity that is to say we
don't simply treat people how to
redesign the environment we think how do
you redesign the figure of the architect
the figure of the urban designer of the
figure of the preservation as the
planner the real estate developer and so
on how do you rethink those fields for
this reason as you know we are we are an
open-ended laboratory a more or less
open source laboratory for testing
experimental ideas about the possible
role for designers in contemporary
society we're not looking for a
particular kind of architecture or even
a particular kind of architect or a
particular
kind of plan or preservationist but a
kind of evolution in the end the
intelligence with which we think about
the build environment this is a very
very unique class in a very unique
moment in history there's a really good
feeling about this class we could be
wrong right it's up to you you know it's
like these are like is like very good
grapes the grapes are good that doesn't
mean that you should drink the wine in
three years or five years or ten years
what looked like the good grapes are not
always the good grapes usually though
usually if the grapes are good the wine
is good and there's no question that the
grapes are good this year the overall
context is of course is is a is a time
of in which everybody's declaring that
we are in crisis I think it's very
important to understand that the word
crisis is used actually after the thing
that provokes crisis happens before
people realize what it is the word
crisis it's a medical term for when you
think that there's a possibility for
living or dying it means it's the
beginning of the thought of a therapy or
or a plan so when people use the word
crisis actually the crisis is usually
passed but for architecture we work on a
very long time frame so basically the
impact of the financial crisis I would
say the ethical crisis the legal crisis
the energy crisis the whatever crisis in
architecture we reflect with a longer
time frame and you are the generation
that will engage with the conditions
that produced crisis I think you are you
uniquely equipped because we put you
into crisis every day here that was your
life your life was to be out of control
in an unknown situation with unknown
responsibilities and none unknown
solutions with teachers that didn't even
give you the dignity of telling you what
you should do and in this sense I think
you you have the ability to play an
incredibly crucial role in rethinking
the role of the professional if you
think of almost any traditional category
in society
our research information communication
there's a there's been a very very
significant shift over the last four or
five years in the definition of those
things this is also very true for cities
and for buildings it was often said that
buildings and cities were different from
everything else because they last longer
and indeed we depended on now on our
buildings for memory the assumption was
buildings will last longer than people
so buildings will talk to us when people
are gone but as you know you live in a
moment in time in which to some extent
cities are changing more quickly than
people people are fundamentally quite
dogmatic quite precise quite restricted
and structured in their beliefs the
cities are now changing so there's been
a complete reversal between the built
environment and therefore a whole
transformation of its capacity and it
will be for you to say what will happen
with this new capacity when cities
evolve more quickly than people then the
question is so what will be the function
of the city what is the that's a
proactive function of the city I think
you are the first generation to have
this assignment I think you're uniquely
able to to deal with it and it will be
an amazing thing to happen you would be
incredibly embarrassed to know how proud
the teachers are review so I won't tell
you about that I will be uncomfortable
and it's some kind of masochism to have
these teachers treating you so badly for
three years and then at the end to tell
you that you that they love you there
are other kinds of love so it would be
Britain in a way better to think your
teachers hated you and continue to hate
you and you're going to take revenge by
doing amazing projects in the world
anyway this is just a long-winded way of
saying it's been an unbelievable
privilege for your teachers to be
working with you and I mean really
working with you this is not a school in
which you have to as it will be drummed
into a particular point of view this is
a school that's not a school of thought
it's not it's a school for kind of
damaging and multiplying
are kinds of thought there is a kind of
let's say philosophy of the school which
is a philosophy of a kind of
biodiversity of philosophies a
biodiversity are approaches and new
forms of collaboration and I think your
generation is the generation of
strategic collaboration this whole
technological transformation that has
occurred in the in the last five six
seven years was absolutely specified in
the 1960s as the inevitable future so
we're now living with a technological
reality that was precisely theorized in
the 1960s so it was almost half a
century in before became realized the
gap between predicting the technological
ethical creative options of the future
and the realities has definitely become
narrower and narrower you're down to
something like a five-year window that's
less time than architects are supposed
to become great after leaving school
you're supposed to be profoundly
distressed for another ten years right
nothing we have done in the school has
fully prepared you for the horror that's
meant to face you upon leaving and
you're supposed to disappear into a very
dark Valley and then slowly come up the
other end desperate and when you get to
the top of the valley on the other side
you'll be given an award for being a
young architects right so imagine you're
crossing some kind of desert you barely
survive many of your friends didn't make
it and when you finally get there they
say you're a young already but things
have changed in that regard as well
because of the change in the world that
we live in you are very very likely to
find yourself on the absolute age of the
most urgent project we had breakfast the
other day in Beijing with a group of
graduates from the program and I
foolishly said after we have breakfast
what are you going to do and and each
person went round the room and then the
youngest person there he hardly looked
older than 10 years
all so sweet so nice it was hard to
believe he was even an architect
absolutely a human being and he said
what he going to do he says it has a
city to finish and this was not his
first city so you are literally in that
generation that may be asked to do a
city or to do a new interface or a new
communication system and so on so I
think the old story about waiting ten
years don't believe it for a second by
the way look at the buildings you love
you love the most and then check out the
age of the architect when they were done
and you will find an amazing number of
the buildings that you love the most by
the people you respect the most we're
done before they were 40 done a few
years after graduation anyway this is
just to say more power to you we're
enormously proud we hope you stay close
to us you hope we hope you let us know
what you're doing the more radical you
are in the world the more believable you
will be the more necessary you will be
the more skills will be urgently
demanded if you had any interest in
being boring you shouldn't have come to
this school so don't you dare even think
for a moment that one of your possible
professional outcomes is to become more
boring less obnoxious less fashionable
more routine because you think that's
the pathway to success no the skills
that you have the professional skill
that you have is to be constantly
endlessly irritating you will irritate
assumptions you will develop new ways of
being beautiful new ways of being
thoughtful new ways of being responsible
and you will be beloved for that and
this is very very very important many
many times in the history of our field
the three thousand or so years of
history in the West 5,000 through
ancient China you want to start talking
about Jordan you have to talk Neolithic
the oldest city in the world was
discovered this oldest Street in the
world was discovered half a kilometer
from the center of a man and Jordan and
it's 10,000 years old so for ten tower
years we've been working on this city
thing and the thought the thought now is
that probably cities have to be the most
agile most interactive most dynamic
aspect of our society this reversal is
going to be your responsibility I'm
amazed and intrigued to know what you're
going to do with this fact right now
cities are as liquid as anything else in
your life they may be the most liquid
thing for some of you this is a
nightmare this means global capital is
without limit without restriction but as
experts in the shaping of form and the
regulation of form and the protection of
form as architects as planners as
preservationist and so on you are the
ones that can decide what is the meaning
of this and this answer will be super
practical and at the same time a super
philosophical so again I'm pleading with
you pleading with you don't you dare get
boring and if you do will hunt you down
right the real purpose of the Alumni
Association is to track down anybody who
accidentally got boring on us I'm sure
you won't and I'm sure what we will
discover when we stay in touch with each
other is some of the most beautiful
decisive work being produced on this
planet and all power to you
the other thing you got to discover when
you're out there and what they used to
call the real world is Columbia
graduates do damage all over this planet
by chance last night it was in Ellis
Island the house for the dream of
America the dream of a different life
different opportunity a dream that if
you were to look at its written
description sounds very much like the
description of an incredibly good
architecture school and it was looking
up and of course the vault of the
ceiling was a Guastavino volt just just
like this one but what I didn't know
until last night is that the architect
of Ellis Island was one of the very
first graduates of this school so one of
the really weird things you're going to
discover is people are going to want you
to take over responsibility for some of
the most important parts of the planet
of your world and you're going to
discover when doing that there are a lot
of colleagues from this school who are
around you constantly and and all of
whom when when they were given those
assignments just thought there's just no
way that this was a huge mistake but
there was this was a kind of identity
error you're the generation that's going
to be given that responsibility don't
don't lose it anyway first of all Lori
Hawkinson wonderful architect in New
York City and great teacher and leader
director of the advanced architectural
design studios is going to read the
names of the successful victims of the
mr program
ok you ready ok great catherine marie
Atwater John Michael Becker
rusev and fauna Benjamin
Jacob Richard Benny
Anna Maria bogan don t
Derek borin
yuval yaakov borrachos
Brian Wayne brush
Kelsey Eileen Campbell Galligan
you know Chang
Laura Jane Charlton
Qian Qiang Cho
jun ho cho
Christina Nicole chart do low
Wayne William Conger
any serious coombs
Lucas Wayne deck Inga
Lisa jhene aiko
eleonora alcova and Chava
lena dal Peng fun
Luca foreign Ellie
Mustafa Ali farooqi
Karen and faye
Rajiv John Fernandez
Robin Fitzgerald green a muy clarity
Ashley and Ainge
christopher lawrence key
Melissa tapper Goldman
it's melissa Elaine Goldman Keith
Greenwald
jessica renee health and tally andrew
michael jacobs
petra jar olam ova
Robert Elton Johnston
joon-young
Talia kahane
soon godkin
Malika ain Kirkland
a nice air curtain
David do kwan
Devon Zelman lefoux
here's one is open Camilla Comstock King
doke Lancaster
Elizabeth Lasater
ho Kyung Lee
young charlie
mark Harold LaVon
debin inland
chrystal lee logan
Megan Ashley Lynch
page Marie mater Zoe whiner melero
Ruth cordula mandal
Peter Andrew Morgan
Rihanna mo Safari Dana
danelle Nagi
saranga Luthra nikuda
Amy Elizabeth nism Naomi Allison oko
Hugh nil Oh kisa OU
Julian page fanpost
see you in park
Alison Claire Patrick
Stephanie mayor power
Christian Aaron pash
ravi raj
Justin Morgan Rennels
nicole elizabeth c CLE
ji-yong so
Hayes share
Peter Thomas Strauss
eric lin gong say
Stephanie sin hang tongue
Irene or minetta
michael james walsh
Evan wants
Nicholas thomas weis
and Ken bo yang
congratulations this is the class of
you
and now I'd like to invite the wonderful
professor andrew dahl card who's
director of the historic preservation
program to present the brilliant
historic preservation class of 2010
andrew
this is the most thrilling thing I do
all year yiannis ever Metis the engine
in bak hush
Gillian Hayes connell oh no Ruth cooks
Justin Paul Greenawalt
Catherine Louise husband
mia cowan linear
LLS in Meredith Lions lodging Michaela
Lisa Marie Michaela dong min park
um when
Thomas all Rome aldi season shade
Kathryn Lawson Smith
and Barbara leinbach CA
with historic preservation 2010
so I'd like to introduce another
wonderful colleague professor Robert
Beauregard director of the program in
urban planning
Christopher Raymond Bauman
audra Leslie Brecker
Brian Wayne brush
Virginia Carver
Gillian Hayes con el
but not Adam ng dragon
Caitlin rose damn askin
Louise Nielsen dryer
john matthew du lac
Jesse farm
vikram singh gill
Sanae Astrid ghosting
mikail kanina gross Kristina one
Margaret Virginia Hudson
Paul Lorenzo James
sang you can
Peter James cats
David more crew with Sophia Hakeem
lelani Jung Hwan Lee Kevin Peter leitner
shall weigh me
young Jane Lee
Alison que mire
jomel era
leah marie Moselle Yong Yong ho toh low
on our Christian joy on gan cao
Jennifer Lee pair
Alexandra Sophie Rose us
Brendan shower
sourish in
james howard simmons jr
ki Hong song
it toss on a Pollock heat the soup emoni
Joseph Sunday
Oh
Kevin judge Thurman
matthew viggiano
k see why
Andrew Watanabe
neng shi woo
on way you and David Christopher's I
so this is planning of 2010
and it's really a pleasure to award the
PhD in architectural history theory and
criticism to chaka vandermeulen who
graduates this year
so some prizes the William Kinney
fellows Memorial traveling prizes these
for the parents and family and friends
these are projects that the students
proposed super super competitive
probably the only prizes the students
really really care about and if you
listen to the sound of these projects
the name of these projects you are
hearing the future of the field so
firstly they're in different categories
from the from the architecture
subcommittee for for Kenny project that
it's impossible for me to say and
therefore was clearly worth the prize
goodbye Kruschev aqui de new
for a research project entitled
mechanical squids colossal Giants and
towering elephants Melissa Elaine
Goldman and Megan Lynch
for project entitled regionalism and
innovation a discovery of building
practices in South America nyomi akko
and Evan watts
a project entitled the architecture of
security the role of drawing in
hypersensitive conditions Christina
Cheadle oh and Mark Libyrinth
a project entitled transnational
currents Lisa Okla and Keith Greenwald
for a project entitled learning off the
grid a study of alternative educational
systems in India Annie curtain and ravi
raj
for project entitled road trip driving
through prison towns yong-jae lee and
peter Strauss
and now from the historic preservation
subcommittee for a project entitled
conservation cleaning treatments for
stone considering laser based methods
Katherine Smith
from the urban planning sub-committee a
project entitled noble southern twin
lessons from australia joseph trendy
now for the sort of school-wide penny
awards for project entitled deep water
case studies in reserved merchant ships
Thomas Rinaldi from preservation
a project entitled appropriation of
space buda-pesht critic Audra Brecker
dprk mapping transgressions of
communication Chris key and janja he
obsolescence found and lost towards an
alternative future for oil rocks when
Conger and Luca farinelli
and the final kinney award goes to a
project called post reservation housing
economy and infrastructure in the Lakota
reservations Annie Coombs and Zoe
malaria
the historic preservation program awards
start with the thesis Awards the first
is for the best thesis in the history of
historic preservation for project the
for the project is the the intergalactic
award for the advisor Andrew doc had the
topic was the preservation of trinity
church yard and the winner is Alison
Meredith
for the best thesis on the preservation
planning issue with the adviser of carol
clark is a project entitled Pittsburgh's
East Liberty project preserving the
artifacts of the urban renewal era
Justin green wife
for the best thesis on an issue of
preservation policy with the advisor of
Tony would a thesis entitled enforcement
in the New York City landmarks law past
present and future Benjamin vikash
and the preservation alumni is Cleo and
James Marsden fitch thesis grand prize
with the name of the founder of the
program for her thesis entitled cultural
landscape as a foil and political
struggle Susan Shay
now it gets serious the historic
preservation student peer-to-peer awards
to the student whose whole hearted and
generous participation in the life of
the preservation has program has earned
the respect of the student body and the
most respected person is Justin
Greenawalt
rspec t okay urban planning program
awards the Charles Abraham's thesis
award for the master's thesis that best
exemplifies a commitment to social
justice the advisor was Robert borough
guard and the winner is James Simmons
the planning challenge award for a
master's thesis that makes a substantive
contribution to our understanding of a
contemporary planning issue the advisor
professor Elliot sklar and the winner is
Kevin Thurman
the planning research design award to a
thesis that exemplifies a commitment to
research methodology and or planning
techniques with the advisor professor
David King Yee Hong Hong
the American Institute of Certified
planners outstanding student award for
outstanding attainment in the study of
planning goes to Renata de min ji
dragline
and the urban planning program award for
high academic attainment goes to John du
Lac
the new york chapter of the american
planning association award for academic
excellence and leadership in urban
planning goes to Margaret Meggie Hudson
the urban planning student peer to peer
award to the student whose dedication
reliability and sheer willingness to
help others has earned the respect of
the student body goes to Atia sunup area
the bill Center for the Study of
American architecture awards starting
with the Catherine Hoover of all saying
a writing prize which is awarded by the
temple hoyne buell Center for the Study
of American architecture for the most
outstanding essay on American
architecture and this year the writer of
this was advised by Jorge Elias of the
preservation program and the master's
thesis winning the writing prize is the
thesis entitled Whitney Warren's private
preservation campaign in nineteen
fourteen to eighteen and the paradigm
for private international preservation
intervention I Oh Ana's Varmus
the Percival and now Amy Goodman
fellowship is made possible through the
generosity of Raymond lush a graduate of
the architecture program in 1957 and a
teacher here at the school from 1961 to
1970 in honor of his former teacher
colleague and friend the remarkable
Percival Goodman the purpose of this
fellowship is to enable the recipient to
carry out a project of social
significance related to the interests of
Percival Goodman this is an award that
increasingly goes to the heart of
student and faculty interests there are
two sets of winners for this award the
first is for two people doing a project
entitled post reservation visualizing
housing economy and infrastructure and
the Lakota with tohko reservations any
Coombs and Zoe areas
this is by the way a very high-powered
award with the absolute top of the
scholars of the school judging who
should have received it the second such
award is given to a project entitled the
propagation of fear architecture
religion and politics addressing the
recent ban on minaret construction and
Switzerland mark liver
okay architecture program awards okay
the studio teacher has to say who's the
best sorry 12 students one winner it's
tough here we go ed Keller his choice
for his studio entitled crypto form is
three people right off the bat you Val
birch off Lisa elke and Dan Nagi
professor Michael Bell studio entitled
Paris Texas award goes to Karen Fey
Laurie Hawkinson and Shawn Geller her in
their studio entitled the 50-kilometer
studio infrastructure energy and new
territories which was a project for the
bridge in the Hong Kong Pearl River
Delta macau linked to winners Laura
Charlton and any curtain
keith casements absolutely wonderful
studio made for Rio operational amateurs
the winner is keith greenwald
that's a studio that knows how to dance
ada tolerant giuseppe lynn yanos
monographs to do the winner this year is
christina to your dollar
suen yanks to do reconstruction updating
the city block the winner is Jacob
beignet
Toro has Ogawa's studio computing kaisan
gives the prize to Robert Johnson
Ryan Howard Madden's studio public
housing and Mumbai gives a prize to
yong-jae lee
Leslie Gil and Mike Jacobs to do rates
of exchange surface and deficit in the
Amazon to prize winners hyun yellow and
see young park
Mario Gooden's studio entitled radical
mutations Quinn bo yang
now the emag students nominated Avery
six awards the first one is to the to
the student whose ridiculous commitment
to the school at large has earned the
respect of the student body Christian
prash
this one is close to my heart to the
student whose work questions the
standards of architecture and promises
to change the profession Daniel Nagi
building technologies Honor Award to the
student who most demonstrates an ability
to incorporate building technologies
into the issues of architectural design
very very important award goes to
eleonora and shaver
the visual studies Honor Award for
innovative use of computing media in
architectural urban research design and
fabrication goes to Melissa Elaine
Goldman
first the school service awards are for
outstanding service to the school and in
this school students are unbelievably
important in the day-to-day life of the
school so when David and his colleagues
select a group of students to thank them
for their dedication to the school this
this means these are for absolute
miracle workers mother Teresa did not
make it into this list any coombs Luca
finale Brian brush and Melissa tapper
Goldman
now for the AL farouk I medal for
leadership and service to the school and
promise of professional merit ravi raj
the American Institute of Architects
certificate in recognition of scholastic
achievement character and promise of
professional ability goes to jessica
renee Helfand tally
and the American Institute of Architects
metal in recognition of scholastic
achievement character and promise of
professional ability goes to Keith
Greenwald
and now the New York society of
architects Matthew delgaudio award for
excellence in total design goes to
danila Nagi
now there's a series of honor awards for
excellence in design basically the
entire faculty argues for an entire
afternoon passionately in heatedly and
the survivors of that battle the winners
for high-quality work in the design
studios during the students entire
program of studies the first such award
goes to Laura Charlton
Nicholas wise
hume Cheng Chao
Christina toodle-oo
Petra geral him over
young Charlie
Eric see
and this is a joint award for the first
time in the history of the school to who
Neil oh and seein park
so that was an award to one designer and
now the Charles McKim prize for
excellence in design and the soul kaplan
traveling fellowship this is of course
the most prestigious award and the award
that carries the name of the architect
of this campus and of this building this
is to recognize the student whose work
throughout the studios has been
absolutely outstanding funded by
bequests from our lumps or kaplan who
graduated in from architecture 1957 and
the prizes for travel and study
following graduation and the winner of
the of the most prestigious award in
this school is any Curtin
so before we disappear for some coffee I
just want to take this opportunity to to
thank david hinkle without whom there
would be no nothing and who is at the
absolute center of the intellectual and
administrative and personal lives of
absolutely everybody in this school
around David is a remarkable team of
Swiss Army knives all of whom today he
became ticket ticket takers marshals
psychologists photographers and so on I
could not be more lucky than in working
with the team of people that I work with
and all of this comes from David and his
leadership this is somebody who
completed his PhD while running the
school on a daily basis as a real
superstar you know really arrival within
Ricky Walker in the nicest guy of the
Year award it's been tough it was such a
bloody battle that we canceled it but
David is a genius and there is an
endless kindness and sophistication to
his work which all of us here benefit
from but it never received some kind of
label but it would like us all to thank
david hinckley
so it's time for coffee but just for for
one last time all the best please stay
stay in touch your wounds will heal on
average 15 16 years sometimes occasional
traumatic memories and and strange
things that you will say to your
children and so on but other than that
you survived you're doing really really
beautiful work great spirit in the
school during the end of your show great
feeling in the atmosphere the best work
has quality that you can't see in the
drawings and in the models but somehow
in the room and when all of you put your
work side by side we all knew we were
seeing something very very special so
don't screw it up just get better and
better and better and annoy a lot of
people and do wonderful things and have
your stuff come back and be honored and
go into Avery library I mean this is the
main point here is that we could once
again celebrate you in the way that you
deserve which is just to simply have
your projects placed within the official
library of record and seen by the
students will be in the school in 100
years from now trying to understand what
it meant for you to graduate in 2010 but
all the best and for me personally it's
been a great ride and nevertheless
coffee is really really important in the
School of Architecture we've gone a long
time without it so congratulations the
class of 2010
you